who are retaining half of Johansson's salary
here's McKinnon he'll hand it off to ma WR
shot block and the rebound as linan set it just
wide ABS keep it in everybody's been on for the
entire power play penalty kill and power play mck
Kinnon will load up and fire at M clockwood able
to knock that away it was up in the air maybe
would have headed in but he saw it located it
and cleared it away they are definitely two of
the core players here for the Colorado Avalanche
and their general manager Chris McFarland of
course president the former NHL Great Hall of
Famer Joe sack you throw McKinnon M Taves and
Randon in there that's your core and they've
got a bunch of great players complimentary the
Sharks though have the first goal of this one on
the shot by Matt Ben one nothing and Thomas
bordo has his first National Hockey League
goal all from a dump in good Puck punishement
good job on the four check and the goal watch
where Barlo Barlo facing it stick is well below
the crossbar a perfect deflection a great job by
Mike Hoff M Kennon Ed by his former teammate
Sturm lost the puck went to linan though he
gets it back and Blackwood great save and then
covers no rebound available for Joe Hanson or
linon in front good job by the Sharks protecting
the middle there a lot of outside opportunities
here's McKinnon trying to get inside he does and
Blackwood with a great save and then it's pulled
off the goal line back there by Burrows Wheels
it all the way up top for Jack Johnson ready to
shoot as the hands off the pass and Manson shot
wide rebound somebody got a stick on that was
it Blackwood because the net was avilable there
as that one came hot off the backboards lots of
traffic in front of the San Jose goal kudos to Ken
Holland GM and Edmonton and Jay woodcr their coach
they made sure that 700th gain happened as they
called him up from baker's field for that night he
talked about right here good to see JD again we're
underway here with the second period at the Shark
Tank the former shark the late briyan Marchman
when he was with the Edinson Oilers going into
the open gate here's a two-on one Hoffman shoots
saved by gorz here's William eckan weeds his way
in once barabanov ends up playing the puck himself
it bounces to a Colorado player Olson he'll come
across now with kale marar oh was a threat Olson
the shot and McKenzie Blackwood with another huge
St stop this time short-handed ni rman checked by
kenot in comes Luke cunan and now baronov against
Byrum go inside ABS unable to hold the Zone here's
a breakway for Luke cunan Sav by gorv and C it
ends up in the net by gor GV good work by Peterson
to get the puck and then Luke go straight ahead
but what I love he gets tripped right at the end
there I do believe he didn't lose his balance oh
no he did I'm sorry he did lose his balance after
the shot going up in the glove gorv with the save
only goal from Thomas bordalo is first in the NHL
back at 842 of the first here's a stretch pass to
Joe Hansson Johanson for NuSkin walks in Blackwood
gets the pad down makes the save Brandon after it
for Colorado he'll give it up to javanni Smith
for the sharks with Sturman Z no way that's a
nice Smith will hunt it down they wave it off
gets in front for zland saved by gorv and the
fourth line creates a great scoring opportunity
on pure hustle L Car drops for McKinnon he busts
his way in and hands it off Joe Hansson into the
slot and lein and denied by Blackwood beautiful
save Hoffman trying to win the battle down low
Manson there as well for Colorado and the ABS
break it out here's Logan o Conor with cogliano
shoots off the [Applause] post has the potential
to explodeed any minute but McKenzie Blackwood
and the group in front of him so far tonight and a
flipper headed toward Tomas hurdle he can't settle
it we're back to five aside here's linan skating
in and Blackwood with a stick save pivit away from
Ruda finds J Gerard open cross eyes te behind Joe
Hanson now in front linan and he hit the post what
a play by linan spin around F of the puck but you
know what that's all because the puck didn't
get deep here's Mar pulls the trigger blocked
by cunan up with the puck he's got barabanov on a
break Alexander barabanov in on goal and a penalty
[Music] coming not a penalty shot it'll be holding
and a power play for the Sharks B byro mcar
thought about going wide on zland now he leaves
it for Nathan McKinnon he'll shoot save rebound
and Blackwood with his best save of the night
off K Mard drwan to Byrum looks off ranton gives
it back for drwan and he hit him up in the face
here's McKinnon skating in and Blackwood shuts the
door what a debut for number 29 inal
good support coming out Eco sturb and
now zland with stur stur shoots saved by
gorv Brandon to marar cut shoots that one
deflex wide still alive for Colorado
now cunan didn't see the puck here's
nushin he's checked by Benning B to chushin
back for kale mar mar loads up shoots and
scores with 126 to go Colorado was tied at
1-1 on the goal by Kale Mar didn't see it the
puck stays in the zone and watch the screen in
front there's big Val lusin McKenzie Blackwood
can't see the puck doesn't know where it is goes
through four bodies Val the cuskin in front of the
net 5 minutes or less of three on three
this time it's McKinnon to take the face
off and hoop able to hold the Zone back over
to William eckan eckan down low declair back
for eckan eckan to declair declair shoots Gori
of the save and this one's going to go to a
shootout effort you know there's some
things you can can control Randy effort
is one of them and you've seen it tonight
from the Sharks as barabanov waits for the
all clear from the referee and he's got it
and here's the first shootout by Alexander
barabanov and a save by gorv who just
stayed with barabanov and blocked
that backhander yeah he sure did watch
the second effort by gor off here that
that little extra push right nice play
Nathan McKinnon will do the honors for
Colorado as McKenzie Blackwood gets set here's
McKinnon and and Blackwood down with the pads
makes the save the big man to try to get around
McKinna 1 2 3 4 now he's going to go hard around
try to put it on the forehand side watch again
the agility niik ranton and he has the 55 goals
last season the second shooter for the Avalanche
and he scores what a shot as he picks the corner
and the Avalanche in front here with a golden the
shootout and the Sharks need one now to extend it
yeah boom quick off the stick right don't let
the goalie know you're going to shoot [Music]
itman a must score situation here
in round three for Mike [Applause]
Hoffman and gorv shuts the door the
Avalanche come back and win it in the
shootout